alors jacques tu as eu une enfance elle
à la dickens un peu un peu ton père
avait fait la guerre de 14 il était
parti à 20 en carrière à 104 faire la
grande guerre oui il en était devenu
complètement excentré et du vin poids au
parc un peu c'est un euphémisme
il buvait tout le temps du whisky nancy
lui tomber dessus
ouais une fois il paraît qu'il a vu de
l'autre colonne aie aie ça doit être
pour ça que j'ai les cheveux bouclés
il en est mort oui j'en est mort mais il
a pris son temps c'est un homme par toi
tu t'es retrouvé au collège au collège
elle est ce lui convenait pas voir très
souvent pas trop non mais gt gt dans un
collège dans un collège catholique et
j'ai reçu une éducation très dures qu'il
m'a fait trouvé après la vie
merveilleuse pression d'être en vacances
mais à l'édition
c'était mal vu parce que ta mère pays en
retard oui un petit peu mais qu'ils ont
tu sais tout je sais tout et dans cet
art c'était une enfance assez morose
désirez pas avoir du chocolat au collet
voilà mais il alluma vivent là le plus
jeune n'a pas encore écrite avait un
enfant en direct via des flux entre les
mains oui or c'est assez banal tout ça
mais c'est ce qui conduit ou théâtre et
là j'ai vraiment trouvé une famille et
depuis je n'ai jamais trahi ce qu'ont
ils à faire le pitre collège voilà pour
finir pitre à la télévision finalement
tu trouves cette éducation pas mauvaise
tué parce que tu dis ce qu'il dit
aujourd'hui qu'il faut avoir une
éducation à ces directives pour ses
enfants
je pense que c'est très important que
l'éducation soit unie puni prg dont on
triomphe aujourd'hui tu as six enfants
si ce n'est pas fini t'as pas fini tu
dis qu'ils ont ce qu'ils trouvent tous
super génial et un peu déçu de tout
laxisme
ben moi j'aime mieux que mes enfants me
trouve sympa que dallas mais c'était pas
service à là on est trop sympa avec eux
je pense qu'être père c'est être père
jusqu'où vous moi mes enfants peuvent
compter sur moi jusque dans les pires
moments
je suis leur père dont je suis deux
partis pris c'est eux que j'aime d'abord
je suis là chemin de parti pris pour mes
enfants
fini que la première erreur c'est pas
avoir jeté la bouteille de ketchup le
premier jour tout ça aussi avant j'étais
vexé parce que j'aime la cuisine c'est
dans la famille c'est lui le grand père
était cuisinier du dard et mon grand
père était chef de cuisine du diable
qu'est aussi fait peut-être touché
maintenant que le dard risque de revenir
grâce à vous je risque
tu risques de toucher peut-être l'enfant
russes tu sécurisé le rembourser mais je
sais toutes les familles françaises en
ont plein dans leurs armoires way ou une
pl l'envoyer non je ne pense pas pour
tous d'emprunts russes qui promet pour
revenir aux enfants je pense qu'il ya un
seul truc est important quand on est des
enfants c'est l'exemplarité
quand tu les vois regard des dessins
animés japonais où vous mangez duquette
chef était d'ailleurs à ses passions
mais justement c'est le texte avait mis
des petits mots dans les livres rares
oui j'avais dix vendues pas cette
édition pour acheter un vélo seul vrai à
l'époque
et puis finalement ils n'ont pas touché
non je les en remercie est ce qu'ils
montrent des enfants
bien sûr ça mon bien les enfants aussi
bien que moi un moment très très bien
oui tu vas voir cela
ça